There is a famous quote from Steve Jobs,
where he talks about computers as bicycles for the mind.
He said that back in 1990,
today we have about a 100,000 times as much computing power
as people had back then,
so we should really think about computers as the interstellar spaceships for the mind.
This is pretty amazing. You have in your pocket more computing power
then the most powerful governments in the world had access to 20 years ago.
But what is really great about computing is that computers are universal machines.
This means that you can program them to do just about anything.
We will do this by looking at something most people use every day - a web search engine.
You are not expected to have any previous programming experience entering the class,
but by the end of the class you will understand the big ideas that power a search engine,
as well as how to read and write your own computer programs.
I hope you will join us and enjoy the ride!